il y a pas mort d'homme il y a pas mort
d'homme c'est simple he comme expression
on comprend tout de suite ce que ça veut
dire que c'est pas important et qu'on
peut passer à autre chose à ce qui
compte vraiment il y a pas mord d'homme
ce sont les mots qu'a choisi Jack Lang
ancien ministre pour commenter l'affaire
Dominique stroskanan ancien ministre lui
aussi alors je précise parce qu'il y a
eu plusieurs affaires Dominic
struscan celle du Sofitel de New York où
il a été accusé de viol par Nafisatou
Dialo et en un sens il a raison il y a
juste cette femme de chambre que l'on
retrouve les vêtements maculé de sperm
et les collants troué il y a pas mort
d'homme il y a juste viol de femme juste
un crime quoi et à l'époque la presse et
puis la classe politique aussi avait la
tentation d'essayer de tourner la page
assez vite de vouloirah passer à autre
chose quoi un peu sur le mode oui mais
toute façon tu connais Dominique c'est
un
séducteur alors ça peut paraître loin
New York 2011 mais des affaires il y en
a eu beaucoup en politique depuis il y a
eu l'affaire Donis Baupin il y a eu
George Tron il y a eu Gérald haranin
Nicolas HULLOT Éric Zemour Damien Abad
Adrien
catnins et alors qui sont ces hommes
polities mis en cause pour harcèlement
agression sexuelle violence conjugale
des comportements sexistes et même
parfois des viol et bien il y en a dans
toutes les familles politiques de
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche en
passant par l'extrême centre et puis il
y en a aussi à tous les échangs de
pouvoir du conseiller municipal du petit
village jusqu'au plus haut sommet de
l'État et il vont s'en prendre et bien
soit une femme qui passe par là comme
Nafisatou Dialo soit aux femmes qu'il
côtoi au quotidien ça peut être leur
épouse une journaliste une collègue élue
une militante une administrée ou leur
collaboratrice et collaboratrice
collaboratrice d'élu c'est le métier que
je fais depuis une quinzaine d'années
alors bon c'est pas un métier très connu
c'est plutôt un métier de l'ombre il
faut dire que les rares qui ont pris la
lumière s'appelait pénéope Fillon et
Alexandre benala et ce ne sont pas les
plus représentatif de la profession
puisque au quotidien ben déjà nous on
travaille vraiment et on le fait sans
brassard police alors c'est nous qui
rédigeons les discours des élus qui
Géront leurs réseaux sociaux leur emploi
du temps et puis parfois on réserve un
billet d'opéra pour Madame o on trouve
un stage pour
l'ofiston bref j'ai été assistante
parlementaire et donc je travaillais
pour un assisté
parlementaire la politique c'est un
monde d'homme
si je vous demande d'imaginer le
portrait robot d'un élu aujourd'hui vous
allez me
dire un homme 50 60 ans plutôt blanc et
plutôt pas fâché avec le
pâté et ça n'est pas une caricature
c'est ce que nous montre les chiffres en
fait la politique en France elle s'est
construite par et pour les hommes et
jusqu'aux années 2000 être une femme
était une exception et ça ça laisse des
traces petite ambiance un peu vestiaire
un peu
bistro et pas que chez les boomer on
peut avoir aussi des élus très jeunes et
très
problématiques maintenant mettez-vous
dans la peau d'une collaboratrice et
bien c'est un quotidien qui est fait de
de BIS gluantes quand on tend la main
pour dire bonjour de remarque du
style bonjour mademoiselle on m'avait
dit que vous étiez aussi jeune que jolie
mais je ne pensais pas à ce point mais
ça c'est du vécu euh ce sont aussi des
mains baladeuses ou des photos non
sollicitées et ça ne se passe pas que
sous les ordres de la République ça se
passe aussi en bas de chez vous je vous
rappelle 74 % des élus locals sont
concernés et oui puis j'ai dit dipque ou
main baladeuse mais on parle bien de
harcèlement sexuel ou d'agression
sexuelle c'est important de dire les
termes les termes du Code pénal parce
qu'en fait on est en train de parler
d'élus qui font la loi et qui parfois ne
se l'applique pas à
eux-mêm alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
nous quand ça nous arrive et bien
l'idéal ça serait de les
éviter problème c'est qu'ils sont
nombreux moi quand j'ai commencé à
bosser il m'aurait fallu éviter un
ministre un candidat à la présidentielle
le maire d'une grande ville un président
de groupe parlementaire un directeur de
cabinet un préfet bon ça commence à
faire des des gros gros zigzags si on
doit tous les éviter en fait ça revient
presque à éviter son propre parcours
politique et c'est le choix que font
certaines femmes qui partent parce
qu'elles sont dégoûtées et le problème
c'est que si les dégoûtés s'en vont et
bien il reste les
dégoûtants alors il faudrait parler
parler bon c'est plus facile depuis
Mitou hein parce avant on savait très
très bien se taire mais quand même ça
reste compliqué parce que il y a des
enjeux de rapport de force si vous avez
25 ans et que vous êtes en CDD et qu'en
face vous avez un ministre ou un pure de
la politique bon euh et pourtant vous
dites bah oui il faut parler il faut
parler faut parler il faut aller porter
plainte surtout c'est vrai il faut aller
porter plainte hein c'est ce que nous
disent les pouvoirs publics portez
plainte sinon on vous prendra jamais au
sérieux alors oui il faut porter plainte
c'est plus facile si on a des années
devant soi et des milliers d'Uros devant
soi ça ce sont les chiffres du ministère
de la Justice et de
l'Intérieur en gros ça veut dire que
dans notre pays il y a 0,6 % des
violeurs qui sont condamnés ça
s'explique par beaucoup de raisons la
première c'est que la plupart du temps
les victimes ne portent pas plainte
parce que c'est très difficile d'aller
porter plainte aussi parce que parfois
les plaintes ne sont pas prises ce qui
est illégal et souvent parce qu'elles
sont classées après c'est important de
pouvoir raccrocher à des petites lueurs
d'espoir au cas où ça marche et on a un
cas comme ça en politique alors je vous
donne le contexte c'est une histoire de
viol au pluriel en réunion ça s'est
passé dans une ville de banlieu
parisienne le violeur s'appelle George
Tron son avocat c'était Éric Dupont
Moretti mais ça c'est une autre histoire
et devinez combien de temps le criminel
a passé c'est derrière les barreaux
après 10 ans de
procédure 13
mois voilà 13 pas 13 ans 13
mois je pense qu'on pourrait tous et
toutes souhaiter pouvoir tout attendre
de la
justice la justice elle n'a que les
moyens qu'on lui donne et qui
aujourd'hui décide des moyens de la
justice c'est le politique
et le politique qui parfois se planque
derrière la justice pour ne pas assumer
ses
responsabilités parce qu'en fait il y a
beaucoup d'institutions défaillantes
faut le reconnaître combien de partis
combien de mairies vont chercher à
défendre à protéger leur réputation
c'est-à-dire leur potes plus plutôt que
de respecter le code du travail par
exemple le code du travail qui prévoit
l'obligation pour un employeur de
garantir la santé et la sécurité de ses
employés prenons un exemple 2022
Emmanuel Macron choisit de nommer Damien
Abad ministre quand il le fait il sait
que Damien Abad a déjà fait l'objet
d'une plainte pour viol et donc il se
dit chic voici le bon candidat pour être
à la tête d'un cabinet le bon candidat
pour être à la tête d'une administration
le bon candidat pour être ministre dans
un gouvernement dont la grande cause est
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes on peut trouver ce type de
raisonnement
hypocrite on peut aussi le trouver
dangereux et c'est dans ce contexte que
certaines victimes vont parfois en
désespoir de cause aller parler à la
presse par exemple à mdiapart ou à
d'autres médias reconnus pour le sérieux
de leurs
enquêtes alors il y en a que ça
horpile je voudrais souligner une chose
c'est qu'une victime de viol
d'agression ne choisit pas le lieu le
moment les circonstances de son viol ou
de son agression
elle les
subit et à partir de là je me dis que
peut-être on pourrait la laisser choisir
quand comment et à qui elle souhaite en
parler surtout que on n rien à gagner à
en parler he regarder les trajectoires
de celles qui ont témoigné au sujet de
Gérald armanin ou de Nicolas HULLOT
elles sont pas devenues ministres ou
personnalité préférées des Français et
puis là je prends des exemples nationaux
mais imaginez au niveau local dans une
petite commune une femme qui serait
agressé par le maire et si le maire est
très copain avec le chef de la
gendarmerie est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment que c'est le correspondant de
la presse locale qui vaer faire une
enquête sur ces deux principales sources
d'information et se les mettre à dos
voilà donc bon n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui
la presse enquête un peu plus c'est un
gros changement par rapport à stroscan à
2011 et c'est
heureux certains
s'inquiètent
d'une un prétendu tribunal médiatique ou
s'inquiète d'un baffouement de la
présomption d'innocence
il faut admettre que oui il faut
respecter la présempptioninnocence de la
même façon qu'il faut respecter la
liberté d'expression et puis la presse
elle ne condamne personne et c'est
heureux puisque ce n'est pas son rôle la
presse elle ne fait que raconter le
monde tel qu'il est raconter les
comportements dont sont capables ces et
ceux qui nous
représente mais comme elle le fait en
fait pour les scandales financiers par
exemple et là ça choque personne qu'on
en parle Paron en fait le vrai scandale
c'est d'essayer de faire reposer sur le
4è pouvoir les défaillances des trois
autres le vrai scandale c'est de ne
proposer aucune
solution parce que les solutions elles
existent ça s'appelle le courage ça
s'appelle la volonté
politique et ça c'est déjà vu hein dans
d'autres registres pendant des années et
des années la politique était gangrainée
par des malversations financière et puis
un beau jour en 2012 le ministre du
Budget Jérôme Cahusac fait l'objet d'un
article de médiap part qui révèle qu'il
a des comptes planqués à l'étranger et à
ce moment-là la classe politique a deux
options continue à mettre la poussière
sur le tapis comme on a toujours fait
avant ou se regarder en face et agir et
franchement ça a été douloureux de se
regarder en face et d'agir mais c'était
possible et depuis une dizaine d'années
vous voyez des ministres des par
parlementaires qui sautent parce que ils
ont bidouillé leur déclaration de
patrimoine parce que ils ont eu recours
à des emplois fictifs ou pour leur
consommation de cocaïne ou même de
Homar
et je ne pense pas qu'une agression
sexuelle ce soit moins grave que des
homars et pourtant à l'époque en 2012 le
président de la République avait ouvert
la voix à la création d'une haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique pour régler ces problèmes
d'opacité financière et aujourd'hui sur
la question des violences sexist et
sexuelles le président de la République
ne propose rien et c'est dommage parce
que ça nous prive d'un cadre clair
commun partagé en fait ça permettrait de
sortir des indignations à géométrie
variable du style ah Bou Adrien catnin
ah mais Bou d'Amien
Abad ce serait
sa à ce stade je pense que vous avez
compris pourquoi la question des
violences sexistes et sexuelles en
politique devrait concerner celles et
ceux qui nous
gouverne mais quel est le rapport avec
vous et bien la politique c'est notre
quotidien c'est notre vie de tous les
jours et pendant longtemps les décisions
en politique elles se sont prises sans
s'intéresser à la vie de la majorité de
la population c'est la loi des hommes
qui a fait que les femmes n'ont pas pu
aller à l'université sans l'autorisation
de leur mari jusqu'en
1938 c'est la loi des hommes qui a exclu
les femmes de la citoyenneté jusqu'en
1944 c'est la loi des hommes qui a
obligé ma grand-mère à demander la
permission à mon grand-père pour
travailler jusqu'en 65 c'est la loi des
hommes qui c'est la loi tout court hein
qui nous a interdit l'accès à la
contraception jusqu'en 67 à l'IVG
jusqu'en
75 et puis puis la loi n'a reconnu le
viol comme un crime qu'en 80 et il a
fallu attendre les années 90 pour
qu'existe enfin le harcèlement sexuel et
le viol conjugal enfin qui existe dans
la loi on sait que ça existe depuis
toujours et ce qui est intéressant quand
on regarde ces réformes c'est que elles
ont été portés par des ministres et des
parlementaires femmes sous la 5e
République alors bien sûr il y a eu
Lucien nevirt le père de la pilule merci
Monsieur mais regardons les autres Simon
veille yvet roui Gisel limi Caine
Génisson Nicol Meline Daniel Bousquet
ellisabeth Guigou c'est quoi le problème
les gars ça vous intéresse pas
c'est des sujets de gonzess
peut-être moi j'ai du mal avec cette
idée du mal à comprendre qu'on puisse
penser que le viol 98 % des auteurs de
viol sont des hommes c'est un sujet de
gonzesse la même façon que les femmes ne
tombent pas enceinte toutes seules et
puis on on ne fait pas nous-mêm le choix
de nous payer 16 % de moins que nos
collègues
masculins et je ne parle même pas des
auteurs de féminicide hein parce qu' il
y a pas mort d'hommes mais parfois il y
a mort de femmes quand
même alors quel est le lien entre ça et
les élus qui pensent que le corps des
femmes est à leur
disposition et bien ce sont eux qui
décident ce sont eux qui dessinent les
contours de notre
société la question qui se pose c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans leur projet
société quelle place y y a-t-il pour les
femmes pour les petites filles qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont faire pour lutter contre les
violences lutter contre les
discriminations qui pourrissent notre
quotidien et puis quel budget vont-ils y
dédier c'est important le budget hein il
est où le milliard réclamé par le Haut
Conseil à l'égalité pour mettre ENF un
terme aux violences
conjugal en Espagne ils ont essayé ça
marche nous on met même pas le tiers de
l'argent sur la
table en fait la question qui se pose
c'est on peut être tous d'accord sur le
fait que les hommes et les femmes
naissent égau en droit mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour que tout le monde en ait
pleinement la
jouissance il en a peutêtre parmi vous
qui pensent qu'on peut être un
pédocriminel et un grand cinéaste
ou un auteur de féminicide et un grand
chanteur de rock ou un violeur en série
un journaliste formidable vous avez pas
les
références pour savoir qui étaient les
hommes ou les artistes enfin on sait
jamais voilà chercheer sur google mais
la question qui se pose c'est c'est pas
ici de gagner une Victoire de la Musique
un César ou un prix Albert Londres on
est en train de parler d'incarner les
valeurs de la
République faire de la politique c'est
c'est non seulement respecter la loi
mais c'est aussi être
exemplaire montrer
l'exemple alors il y a pas mort d'homme
mais vous pouvez
décider vous pouvez faire le choix de
continuer à élire des hommes qui auront
des préoccupations tout à fait
différentes de celle de votre cousine
qui a été violée au weekend
d'intégration de son école de votre mère
qui a été agressée dans les transports
en commun de votre sœur cyber harcelé
sur TikTok ou de votre pote qui n'a pas
eu ses 21 séances d'éducation sexuelle
et affective obligatoire au collège et
au lycée c'est dommage il en aurait eu
besoin
vous pouvez faire un autre choix qui est
celui euh d'écouter la parole des
victimes d'écouter les témoignages
samoncelés de ne pas être de ceux qui
vont dire ah mais oui mais quand même il
faut qu'Adrien retourne à l'Assemblée
c'est quand même un député formidable et
puis il faut attendre que la justice
passe puis 3 mois après quand la justice
est passée de ceux qui disent ah mais
oui mais c'est bon la justice est passée
maintenant Adrien doit retourner à
l'Assemblée c'est un député
formidable et si rien de tout cela vous
convint alors réfléchissez en terme de
priorité est-ce que vous trouvez normal
que certains hommes politiques utilisent
leur mandat pour oppresser des femmes et
que lorsque celles-ci ont l'outrecidance
d'en parler alors ils vont utiliser
leurs moyens institutionnel payé par
vous et moi pour aller expliquer que ce
sont des menteuses et que ce sont eux
les vraies victimes les victimes du
complot De
Mitou la meilleure illustration de ça
c'est peut-être l'histoire de Nicolas ho
Nicolas ho en 2017 il devient ministre
de l'écologie et du climat on parle pas
d'une petite responsabilité hein on
parle bien de l'affaire du siècle
et ce que je me demande c'est combien de
temps il a passé à la tête de ce
ministère à essayer d'étouffer son
propre scandale comme s'il avait rien
d'autre à faire et en fait la vraie
question c'est pourquoi est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron le connaissant l'
choisi lui pour incarner ce poste avec
ce niveau de responsabilité plutôt que
quelqu'un de plus exemplaire quelqu'un
de plus
disponible alors il y a pas mort d'homme
mais de quelle vie veut-on pour les
femmes vous pouvez le décider la
prochaine fois que vous serez dans
l'isoloir la prochaine fois que vous
lirez les programmes avant d'élire le
maire de votre commune ou le député de
votre circonscription vous pouvez faire
le choix de sortir les hommes violents
de la politique vous pouvez ouvrir la
voie à une vie politique plus apaisée
plus inclusive moins masculine et
surtout moins
masculiniste parce que lorsque la classe
politique aura éliminé les violences
sexistes et sexuelles en son
sein alors elle sera enfin à même de
lutter efficacement contre ces mêmes
violences dans l'ensemble de la société
voilà pour pourquoi la lutte contre les
violences sexistes et sexuell en
politique nous concerne toutes et tous
merci de votre
attention